the next topic on the agenda is the ftth
Council Europe award ceremony the ftth
award is given to an individual and to
an operator that have made mouth
standing contribution to ftth adoption
in Europe anyone can contribute
nominations online so please don't
forget to nominate your champion last
year next year the winners are then
selected by the board of directors and
the committee chairs of the ftth council
europe this year our winner in the
operator category is a relatively new
player in the broadband industry they
started building FTTH networks about six
years ago and have since followed an
ambitious growth path for fibre rollout
in Germany based on open access network
infrastructure by 2014 they had over a
hundred thousand households in Germany
already connected to fibre and for 2018
the target has been set us at 400,000
this makes them one of the leading FTTH
operators in Germany ladies and
gentlemen the ftth Council Europe
operator award is given to dota Klaus
father so please let me welcome onto the
stage mr. Jody new and her CEO of the
Godfather and call my president
hey you would like to thank you what I
only see a big light but we're very
honored to to keep this price and
purchase in the new starting point i
would say and also I would like to thank
a lot of people first the board for
choosing us which I think was the right
decision you make the other way I first
I would like to thank all our customers
but without customers we could not build
any good couldn't achieve anything also
we would like to thank our employees
with their motivation and they're
working attitude we could not build out
the network also our supply we would
like to thank and don't forget the
constructors I know they are also here
in in Messiah now and guys thanks a lot
and i hope you will also help us for the
next year's because we have some big
targets to do chief and and we would
like to thank all the cities amazed and
it's all the people who helped us and
last but not least i would like to thank
the banks for the Deaf they gave and our
shareholders so i'll thank a lot for
this wonderful price
[Applause]
thank you very much again
congratulations the second winner the
winner of the ftth individual award has
ever seen the connection of millions of
new homes to FC th and continues to
drive portugal telecom fiber plan for
2020 the story begins in 2004 when he
initiated the first ftp eight studies
that led to field trials in the two
major portuguese cities lisbon and a
photo this cake stops a technological
transformation of portugal telecom fixed
access network they decided to leapfrog
sfgv DSL technology i'm sorry in favor
of a more future proof approach using
FTTH having devoted the last 12 years of
his career to fiber and personally
overseeing deployments to more than 2
million homes around the world he is not
only one of the most experienced
implementers of affiliate in Europe he
is a true champion of fiber the ftth
Council Europe individual award is given
to Luis Moreno
thank you very much I would like first
of all to say my gratitude to the
council and thank you for this
distinction I think that it is a
distinction that does not reflect an
individual distinction but i think that
is also a tribute to all the engineering
teams of all the operations in Europe
that I was building ftth for a long time
we belong to a generation that has a
strong legacy of copper and we have the
unique opportunity to rebuild the
century wide copper networks to a new
future ftth environment and leave this
new legacy to the new generations to
come we know that for sure fiber will be
everywhere and it's requested everywhere
to support the new services the new
technologies and the new business models
that we tell us are implementing as
nadia was saying I was starting to study
and to implement FTTH back in Portugal
also some a little bit in Brazil where I
spent two years of my career in 2004 in
2010 we reach the first million we are a
small country not very big we have about
5.8 million households in this moment we
have together with our own facilities
with FTTH that we'd build with other
with other companies in partnerships we
have already more than 3.2 million
households covered with FTTH we have
been let's say well received by the ftth
Council along the years as a country and
there's a company we have been awarded
in 2011
with the innovation award from at the
ftth council we have also in other other
other players in the market have been
awarded before with this operator
support the vision of implementing fiber
in this moment is a vision that is
aligned with the objectives of the owner
of Portugal telecom altus this is also
the founder of sfa and Maracaibo earring
in france and the project that we are
running of putting out fibre 4 more 3
million households up to the end of the
decade is clearly aligned with this
objective that we have as a group as our
shareholders and as a company that we
want to provide the best infrastructures
and the best services for our customers
and that needs fibrin that needs fiber
to the home and that is dead as it was
said before it requests this fiber to
everywhere and not only to whom I would
I am very pleased and I am very glad to
be able to cooperate together with my
engineering team in Portugal telecom for
the implementation of the new gigabit
society and by doing so together with
the industry and together with also our
service provider partners that are doing
a strong work in the field so I am very
glad to be to to be able to cooperate
and to contribute to some of the vision
and mission of the ftth Council of
promoting ethic ftth to everywhere and
not only to the home and by doing so to
promote the gigabit society as soon as
possible I will leave a final proposal
in challenge to the council as you know
Portugal is the country that is nowadays
posting the web summit it's probably one
of the largest events in the world this
year's
it sorry last year in November it United
more than 50,000 people in 50,000 people
in Lisbon I I think that it will be a
unique opportunity one of them on a
lifetime opportunity to unite websites
and one of the future ftth conference
Englishman thank you very much for this
award thank you thank you thank you for
your patience and we were running a
little late this morning and just one
last word before i freed you for the
lunch break i would like to announce as
you may have seen already in the Flyers
that the next edition the 15th edition
of the FC th conference will be held in
the spanish city of Valencia from the
13th to the 16th of februari 2018 so
please pencil into your Diaries already
now and I hope to see you there next
year and so this is the more the end of
the morning session now you are invited
to visit the exhibition hall through the
tunnel where you will find the lunch
break I hope you enjoy it and please be
back to your children session this
afternoon at two fifteen thank you very
much
you